Please welcome, Anna Chlumsky!
(audience cheering)
Hello.
Hi, hi, hi.
(audience cheering)
How are you?
It's nice to meet you.
It's so nice to meet you.
It's so funny.
I think there are some serious parallels here.
Oh boy. Yeah.
Yeah, I think, I mean, God knows if we have time.
(both laughing)
Well, let's see.
How old were you when you did "My Girl"?
And was that like the beginning or-
That was, so that was my first film.
Right.
You know, I think was put in like,
you know, Carson Pirie Scott ads,
I was put in commercials and things since I was a baby.
I was 10 months old when I did my first print ads.
So, yeah. No chance to be a person yet, at all.
Right?
Oh my gosh.
Yeah. No, yeah.
And then, is it true that you took
a different type of job though?
Well, so my entry level position out of college,
this is when I was definitely,
definitely done with show business.
I was not, you know, I was over it.
And so, yeah, I was a fact checker
for the Zagat food guides.
I don't know if anybody even remembers
or knows them.
I mean,
of course we do!
There was not one...
(audience applauding)
Okay, first of all,
I feel like it was the first way
that we could all become foodies.
Yeah. Yeah, it's true, it's true.
What was it like working there?
That now, it is a survey.
So really, the happiest people working there
were the mathematicians. (chuckles)
'Cause we didn't get to do the eating.
It was all of the public eating,
and they would just tell us what they thought was good.
So I was a fact checker.
I was in a windowless room with two other people
and we made the best of it.
But we had to cold call restaurants and properties
and just go through a 15 minute questionnaire
when they were like at their busiest.
It was-
What was in the questionnaire?
Can you remember a question?
Oh gosh. What's your signature dish?
Uh-huh.
Where are you located?
What are the cross streets?
If it's New York.
(Anna laughs)
(upbeat music)